the u.s capitol is surrounded by
sirens steel and soldiers in a military
occupation
never before seen in the american
capital 25
000 national guard troops secure the
national mall
that's twice the number here after the
1968 assassination of martin luther king
jr
and then there are the thousands of u.s
capitol police city police
fbi border patrol and others
the mob assault on the capitol on
january 6 shown here in a video released
sunday by the new yorker magazine
has left a city and a nation grappling
with the aftermath of an insurrection
fearing another possible assault on
democracy and traumatized
i'm getting a bit nervous towards
wednesday i think it's going to be
better because i think they're taking
like overly precautious
joe biden's january 20th inauguration
comes with crowds reduced by the
pandemic
on ground trampled by a riotous siege
under the shadow of his predecessor's
second impeachment
pennsylvania avenue is usually one of
the busiest thoroughfares in washington
dc
now it is the center of a green zone a
security area that stretches
three kilometers from capitol hill
behind me to the potomac river
this is now a city in lockdown
everyone entering the largest secure
zone in presidential inauguration
history
is screened for weapons inside fences
upon fences steel upon steel just as it
seemed the center of the city was
entirely barricaded
workers bring in still more
fortifications
every manhole cover is sealed against
threats from below
now the city's most iconic street is a
park for runners
rollerbladers and pedestrians enduring a
historic
upheaval my heart feels like a
hummingbird
and i don't know what to do
so i usually go for my daily walk and i
couldn't go for it so
i figured out that i could walk this way
across the u.s the fbi warns of possible
armed
protests outside all 50 state capitals
following the armed invasion in april of
the michigan state house
as federal agents scour the country for
those who invaded the houses of congress
arresting this nashville tennessee man
on sunday the u.s prepares for what most
americans hope will be a peaceful
handover of government power
even as it braces for another assault
john hendren
al jazeera washington